let's play two is the title of my
garyvaynerchuk.com video today and i'm
gonna go into something that i think is
extremely interesting
and i'm gonna break it down for you
because i like to give specifics i don't
want to just preach to you
first of all hope everybody had a
phenomenal phenomenal weekend
please make sure you hug and kiss every
family member you have
that is what life is all about and what
was very ironic about this
uh weekend for me was that yesterday i
spent 13 hours
in a room drafting fantasy baseball
players with a bunch of my friends and
that's where i want to break it down
how fantasy baseball is a clincher and
still an essential part in today's age
2008 march 31st to a lot of baseball
fans a lot of people want to talk about
tradition and hot dogs and in our
culture
and america america's sport and the
steroid era people hitting home runs is
why a lot of people
got back into baseball let me tell you
right now on a gut feeling and i might
not be right but i've got a strong
feeling i pay attention
20 to 40 percent of the people that
watch baseball today
have fantasy baseball implications and
fantasy sports for football see i'm a
huge jets fan so if you're a huge fan of
the yankees or the red sox or cubs or
whoever you are
maybe for you it's not but for a vast
majority of americans right now
most people are watching sports
especially baseball and football
because of the fantasy implications and
that is the secondary market that i want
to talk to you about i don't talk about
fantasy sports
i want to talk to you about how your
company or your personal brand because
now remember
every one of you is now a company your
personal brand tom stevens
johnny johnson what if you're a great
coder at a company right now
and the market dips and we do have a
recession you get let go and nobody
knows about you
why weren't you block blogging or
talking about some of your personal
ideas
everybody should be building their
personal brand it is your best recession
proof mechanism
anyway back to the topic fantasy sports
are the reason i watch baseball i love
the jets and that's why i watch football
but for basketball and hockey
i've fallen off considerably over the
last decade i don't know every
basketball player anymore had i be
playing fantasy basketball every year
i guarantee you that i would i know
minor league players in baseball
backups i know them all strictly because
of fantasy sports and that's what keeps
me
uh you know captivated now the nfl has
done a much better job than baseball
they have the red zone cam right because
somebody's about to score on directv
on all their channels they have fantasy
sports implications espn does fantasy
sports
uh you know things for football much
more than they do for baseball if you
pay attention
i think baseball has missed a huge
opportunity to build it into their
ballparks
into their marketing into the way they
go out after fans
huge mistake huge mistake by major
league baseball by not embracing it more
there should be a lot more activities
around fantasy baseball for baseball
because i think your growth would be
higher and you have more potential
back to the real point secondary
business
why are social networks important for
every company a lot of people say to me
gary what social networks should i be on
when they ask me to consult for them
all of them shouldn't you be everywhere
you can it's like saying gary
here's a great question you're going to
love these guys asking what social
networks
to be on is like asking 10 years ago
should i only advertise on radio
or newspaper or television or guerrilla
marketing
all of them dummy you need to be
everywhere where people are
so many people you know huge you could
be in brazil right now if you go after
bibo
there's a lot of opportunities a lot of
niche social networks
there's a russian classmate site that's
the top 65 websites in the world
you want to be big in russia you can go
there in a heartbeat and be that king of
that domain
um there's just so many opportunities to
leverage social networks and other
opportunities but
if we're going to go even more classic
with your business if you're a lawyer
if you're an accountant a landscaper
understand that there's second-tier
opportunities in your business
there's other sub-markets going around
that can actually
help you build your personal brand or
your company's brand
and brand building my friends is the key
to everything
coca-cola they've been screwing up that
company for 15 years damned made one
good decision
they've missed every market trend and
they're still a huge company
once you build brand equity understand
it is very
very hard to lose it and to break it
it's harder than you think once you get
there the climb up is hard
but getting down is even harder believe
it or not so
what am i trying to really recap because
i've shot a lot of different things you
know i'm scatterbrained it's on monday
what do you want from me it's raining
let me show you it's kind of gloomy out
there but you know i'm excited
because the fact of the matter is is
this it is so clear to me that fantasy
baseball
is a multi-million dollar if not billion
dollar impact
on regular baseball and an exuberant i
have like this exuberance inside because
that means to me like oh my god like
when it hit me today i was like you know
so
brian my good friend brian oh wanted me
to do this title let's play too and i'm
sure they wanted me to go in a different
direction but when it hit me it was like
you know what
what is out there for the wine industry
that i'm missing out where's that
subculture
maybe it's wedding registries right
that's just hit me right now i mean
every wedding needs wine help right why
don't i do five shows on wine
to do with weddings on wine library tv
that would be very viral and a lot of
wedding websites would use that
think about where you can crawl and
where you can hang out
where you maybe don't belong maybe
that's why this wine video blogger got
so involved in social media in the first
place right
doesn't look like you belong but you're
wrong you belong
in every market now think about which
ones can work for you